but first up he is a nine term US
Representative and senior member of the
House Judiciary Committee the person
responsible for all the protesters
outside congressman darrell ices over
here congressman how are you sir thank
you for coming back oh okay
so there are protestors outside but last
week we herded my people those are those
are not your people but they're always
there wha
now last week we had four lastly we
would they said they're gonna be many
protesters for this Milo guy who was on
the show and then no one showed up
because it rained but but this issue
that they're upset with you about having
a Town Hall now excuse me but in 2009 it
seems to be whether the shoe was on the
other foot
the Democrats showed up at the town hall
meetings and took the yelling and it
looks like you Republicans including you
sir are just ducking it really well
that's what they're upset about that you
haven't had a Town Hall we you know we
did have childhood halls in 2009 both
parties did that's when they liked you
no no no no no no but no this is a
serious question it deserves a serious
answer on a serious we town halls are in
fact you sponsored them you bring people
in it's open to the public I had over 14
separate events open to the public in
the last two weeks including one in
which several hundred people showed up
at my my office to protest and I went
out and met with them now I gave in your
office that seems like a small space for
that knows outside my office as a matter
of fact it was outside on both sides of
the street for about an acre uh but the
reality is that there are there are not
enough townhall meetings we have gone to
tell a Town Hall it definitely is is
company more but just so you know bill
there was no problem at all in those 90
minutes with the protesters at my office
there was no problem at all hearing
their fears particularly in two areas
we've got to get the whole question of
immigration and refugees right and we've
got to figure out how to take the fear
out of health care reform and though
that's loud and clear well I think the
question that they're asking is that the
few people who have actually had a real
Town Hall and I can't wait till the
fact-checking comes in on this but I
think the question they keep and I was
broadcast on all the television okay
all right names you Navy all right okay
I've heard different but maybe you're
right but I think what they're saying to
the to the Republicans there is what is
your plan and that is an answer they
just can't seem to come up with what is
your plan
they had years to come up with plans you
know Obamacare it keeps going up in its
popularity it wasn't so popular when it
was the only thing on the table now that
they see there's nothing better now
people are warming up to it what is
better well you know as you know
Obamacare is a term for two things 3% of
the population that are in the exchanges
that are subsidized and the expansion of
Medicaid the reality is it's hard to
unwind both of them what we do know is
the exchanges are going up horrendously
fast because only sick people are in
them we've got to fix that we do know
that the Medicaid expansion is is doing
a lot of good I was at a free clinic
they're not a free clinic but Vista
Community clinic this week and they do
great work they've benefited by the
expansions things they can do including
basic dental evaluations and so on and
just unwinding it 2-0 cannot be the our
answer you're not for repeal and replace
your for fixing it ultimately if what
the Democrats always say if my party
says repeal and replace is how they're
going to express it I'm not going to
disagree with them but yeah yeah but at
least I got the laughs but I didn't have
to ask for it I thought that was good hi
but I'd hardly call that elapsed that's
true but the reality is you're right we
in fact had had a healthcare problem
when Bush left office we have a health
care problem in America health access
and affordability when President Obama
left office and let me know ma any
others oh well many of the money left so
I mean it's a metro for people who are
not getting a subsidy which is more than
two-thirds of America the health care
costs as a percentage of their income
has gone up so in when it comes to
affordability for people who are paying
the taxes and paying for their own
health care directly or indirectly it is
worse now that is not President Obama's
fault however if we do not look at
Canada and other countries and say not
everything they do is wrong their health
care cost half what ours cost we've got
to start looking at the cost drivers and
work on it now that wasn't in the
Affordable Care Act let's collect the
Canada just like the Republicans always
wanted no no but the fact is around the
world probably including Sweden there
are in fact better ideas you know in Wow
it happens I know but Republicans never
say that there are better ideas around
the world what don't you think we're
exceptional here in America
honey hey art otherwise very correct all
right let me get onto it we're going to
run anywhere I may not even getting on
to subject to okay get on to subject you
okay you were a head of the House
Oversight Committee right yes sir you
looked at de Benghazi and fast and
furious and all the IRS and the IRS okay
so about 2000 others
you're right there was it because you
said Obama is one of our most corrupt
president okay so now we have this
situation where it comes out this week
that the Reince Priebus was talking to
the FBI he's the chief of staff that
really is booth no it's not you wish it
was after I finished this question
so anyway so all our intelligence
agencies you have great respect for them
you're a veteran right okay they all
said that the russians hacked one side
like a poker game we're just one player
has the cards up they just hacked the
democrats and we know for a fact that
people in the trump administration had
dealings and talks with the russians
during the campaign okay so let's go
back to 2012 say um the russians hacked
only mit romney mm-hmm and there's a lot
of contact between the Obama
administration and Russia you to let
that slide
no so you're not going to let this slide
no oh so you're going to ask for a
subpoena like Olivia Snowden we're going
to ask the intelligence Committees of
the House and Senate to investigate
within the special areas they know in a
independent prosecutor and
and Jeff Sessions should recuse himself
the same way Loretta Lynch recused
herself because he was part of the Trump
campaign is that correct Jeff Sessions
should recuse himself as I was saying
number two would be you're right that
you cannot have somebody a friend of
mine Jeff Sessions who was on the
campaign and who is an appointee you're
going to need to use the special
prosecutors statute an office to take
not just to recuse that's you can't just
give it to your deputy that's another
political appointee you do have to do
that we're going to have to do it and
here's the reason we're gonna have to do
it bill there may or may not be fault
but the American people who are
beginning to understand that Putin
murders his enemies sometimes right in
front of the Kremlin and then suddenly
the cameras don't work there
he's murdered people and taken down
using cyber warfare in Georgia and in
Ukraine this is a bad guy who murders
people who runs a gas station with an
economy the size of Italy but is
screwing up things all over the world
that we've been doing quote working with
now we have to work with them we don't
have to trust them and we need to
investigate their activities and we need
to do it because they are bad people
well that's certainly not the opinion of
the Trump administration I thank you for
saying that
congressman darrell Issa given credit
for that is
all right Thank You congressman let's
meet our panel